[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم واحد من الاسئله
التي ما كان من غير المتخيل ان تطر على
الساحه السياسيه هو هل يمكن لمصر ان تخو
مواجهه عسكريه خامسه ضد اسرائيل
هذا السؤال هذا الاحتمال بات مطروحا في
الايام القليله الماضيه بعد انطلاق طوفان
الاقصى ليس فقط على مستوى الشعبي ولكن
ايضا على مستوى النخب
والنخب يعني بيستبح على الاقل نظريا او في
المدى القصير المواجهه العسكريه لكنهم لا
يستبعدون تظهرا كبيرا مع اسرائيل يعني بين
مصر واسرائيل واحتمال مواجهه متعدده
المستويات بعيدا عن المواجهه العسكريه
لبحث هذا الموضوع و التعرف على ابعاده
المختلفه انا بستيف مجددا استاذي الدكتور
احمد يوسف احمد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
مساء الخير معال الدكتور مساء النور يا
استاذ سيد والف شكر على الاستضافه وعلى
اثاره هذا الموضوع طب اسال حضرتك السؤال
مباشره هل حضرتك كاستاذ علاقات دوليه
تستبعد مبدئيا تدهور العلاقات بين مصر
واسرائيل في الشهور المقبله لا يعني تدهور
العلاقات هو يعني قائم في اي لحظه نتيجه
السياسات الاسرائيليه لكن السيناريو
المحدد الذي تحدثت حضرتك عنه بشان احتمال
مواجهه عسكريه مصريه اسرائيليه بسبب احداث
كتلك التي تجري الان هذا امر مختلف دعني
اتتبع بسرعه تطور العلاقات المصريه
الاسرائيليه في مرحلتين المرحله الاولى
اتسمت
بصراع يعني واضح وسافر وحقيقي حروب
متتاليه حرب
1948 التي دخلتها مصر مع خمس دول عربيه
اخرى و عدوان اسرائيل بالتواطؤ مع
بريطانيا وفرنسا على مصر في 56 وعدوانها
على مصر وسوريا والاردن في
1967 ثم رد مصر وسوريا الصاع صاعين
لاسرائيل في حرب اكتوبر
1973 هذا نهيك
بالمواجهه المواجهات المحدوده التي كانت
تحدث مثل مثلا غارت اسرائيل على غزه في
1955 ومثل معركه التوافيق على الجبهه
السوريه عندما كانت سوريا جزءا من
الجمهوريه العربيه المتحده مع مصر فاذا
هناك مرحله كامله
من التفاعلات
الصراعيه المسلحه بين مصر واسرائيل هذه
المرحله بدات في الانتهاء بمبادره الرئيس
السادا بزياره القدس في
1977 التي افضت لاحقا الى التوصل الى
اتفاقيتي كامب ديفيد في
1978 ثم الى معاهده السلام في
1999 ومنذ ذلك الوقت بدات العلاقات
المصريه الاسرائيليه يعني تؤطر في اطار
جديد قائم على التفاعلات
ا السلميه صار هناك ا اعتراف متبادل
علاقات
دبلوماسيه المعاهده ايضا لا تنص ليست فقط
معاهده سلام ولكنها تنص على انه لا يدخل
اي طرف من
طرفيها نصيرا لطرف ثان يعني يقوم بعمل
عسكري ا لطرف ثالث يقوم بعمل عسكري وهكذا
يعني مصر لا تدخل حربا نصره لطرف ثالث ضد
اسرائيل واسرائيل ايضا لا تدخل مع طرف
ثالث ضد مصر بالض اه اللي هي ترجمت
بالنسبه لمصر انه الالتزامات الوارده في
هذه المعاهده لا تعلو عليها التزامات اخرى
لان مصر طبعا عضو في اتفاقيه الدفاع ا
المشترك مع العرب ااع العربي المشترك اه
1950 فطبعا هذا اطار جديد
للعلاقات المصريه
الاسرائيليه في تقديري ان مصر لا يمكن ان
تبادر بخرق هذا الاطار اولا لانها حققت
مصالحها من هذه المعاهده باسترداد ارضها
بالكامل تمام و
يعني ثانيا لانه يعني لن يكون هناك اي خرق
لهذه المعاهده الا في حاله الدفاع عن
النفس وانا اتصور ان اسرائيل لا يمكن ان
تبادر بعمل عسكري ضد مصر لانها تعرف جيدا
حجم مصر ووزن
مصر العسكري وبالتالي مصر دوله حققت
مصالحها من المعاهده وتحترم التزاماتها
القانونيه لانها كما تحترم التزاماتها مع
اسرائيل تريد من الاخرين ان يحترموا
التزاماتهم
ا تجاهها ف من من هذه الزاويه لا اتصور ان
مصر ستخر المعادله الا دفاعا عن النفس وما
وقلت ان اسرائيل لن تفكر في المديين
القصير والمتوسط في ان تعتدي على مصر
لانها تعرف وزن مصر وادينا شايفين الان
ماذا تفعل اسرائيل احنا ابتدينا الاسبوع
الثالث من المواجهه مع فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ليس كلها وانما في غزه يعني
بقى لها اكثر من اسبوعين تقف على حدود غزه
تفكر في كيف تدخل بريا فما بالك بقى اذا
قررت نقض تعهداتها مع مصر اذا السلام بين
مصر واسرائيل محمي بالسياسه التي تتبعها
مصر في التقيد بالتزاماتها المصريه ومحمي
ايضا بان مصر لم تعد لها مطالب لا اقليم
ولا غير اقليميه تجاه اسرائيل ومحمي بقوه
جيشها لان اسرائيل لا يمكن ان تبادر
بالاعتداء عليها لانها تعرف الوزن العسكري
لمصر جيدا هذا شيء لكن اذا عممنا الفكره
وتحدثنا عن المواجهه بصفه عامه لا يمكن ان
تكون طبعا هناك مواجهه سياسيه مصريه
اسرائيليه وقد حدث هذا
بالفعل منذ اللحظه الاولى لتوقيع اتفاق
السلام هل نسينا ازمه طابه
والخلاف حول يعني تبعيه او حول وضع علامات
الحدود وما الى هذا وكيف لجات مصر الى
التحكيم وحفظت حقها بهذه الطريقه لكن كانت
هناك مواجهه هل ننسى ان مصر لانها
بالاضافه الى التزامها بالسلام مع اسرائيل
تلتزم كل الالتزام بالحقوق الفلسطينيه
وطبعا اسرائيل كما نعلم لا تحترم الحقوق
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي كلما مارست اسرائيل
عدوانا على فلسطين او على دوله عربيه
توترت العلاقات
وحدثت مواجهات في
1982 مثلا بعد ثلاث سنوات فقط من معاهده
مع اسرائيل غزت اسرائيل لبنان فسحبت مصر
سفيرها من لبنان هذه مواجهه ع سنوات وظل
عده سنوات مسحوبا يعني بالضبط كده
وتكرر نفس الامر في سنه 2000 ايام انتفاضه
الاقصى والممارسات الاسرائيليه تجا الاقصى
الثانيه اه ما هو الاولى اصطلحنا على اننا
نسميها انتفاضه الحجاره دي انتفاضه الاقصى
في سنه 2000 ايضا سحب السفير ثم سحب في
عام
2012 بعد
العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه فاقصد او ما
اريد ان اقوله ان طبيعه السياسه
الاسرائيليه تدفعنا دفعا الى مواجهات
سياسيه وليست مواجهات ا عسكريه وها نحن
نرى الان الموقف المصري الصلب في مواجهه
السياسه الاسرائيليه الراهنه محاوله تهجير
سكان غزه يعني كنوع من النكبه الجديده
تكرار لنبه
48 الخلاف او محاوله اغلاق المعبر وكل هذه
الامور مصر تبنت فيها مواقف صريحه وواضحه
فاذا اذا فكره المواجهات السياسيه قائمه و
وتحدث ومن الطبيعي ان تتكرر طالما بقيت
السياسات
الاسرائيليه على ما هي عليه ايضا هناك
مواجهات اعلاميه لانه من يتابع الاعلام
المصري الان بكل
يعني اشكاله والوانه سيجد ان هناك
لغه اعلاميه شديده الصرامه في التصدي
للافعال الاسرائيليه سواء قنوات رسميه او
غير رسميه سواء صحف رسميه او غير رسميه
هناك اصلا هناك ايضا بعد من ابعاد العلاقه
لم ينشا اصلا وبالتالي لم تحدث فيه
مواجهات لان التطبيع لم يحدث فيه اصلا وهو
البعد الثق قافي يعني بينما مع ان
المعاهده تنص على تطبيع شامل لكننا جميعا
نعلم ان الشعب المصري من تلقاء نفسه لم
يوجهه احد لانه ايضا هذا ميراث تاريخي
بالعكس ده هو حتى لما كانت في في بعض
الفترات الحكومه راغبه في تحسين العلاقه
بشكل اوسع مع اسرائيل كان في رفض شعب يعني
طبعا لان اصل يا استاذ سيد
يعني تاريخيا الجيل الذي حضر معاهده
السلام وما بعدها هذا
يعني حضر لو كان مثلا عمره 40 او 50 سنه
حضر حروبا
ثلاثه اسف حروبا اربعه 48 و56 و67 و73 وما
من بيت مصري الا وفيه شهيد او جريح او شيء
من هذا هذا القبيل
فذاكرة
كانت شديده الوضوح في بعد التفاعلات
الثقافيه لانه باستثناء افراد يعدون على
اصابع اليد الواحده زاروا اسرائيل
وتفاعلوا معها لا توجد تفاعلات ثقافيه او
علميه من اي نوع وعانوا كثيرا
طبعا وحضرتك تعلم ان النقابات المختلفه
تحرم هذا وهذه ت مثلا نقابه الصحفيين
يساءل ويحاسب وينبذ الصحفي اللي يفكر في
الذهاب لاسرا ونفس الشيء بالنسبه لنوادي
اعضاء هيئه التدريس في الجامعات وغيرها
وده قبل الاحداث دي ده من سنين يعني اه
طبعا طبعا فبقول لحضرتك انه
هذه المواجهه لم تحدث في المجال الثقافي
لانه لم تحدث تفاعلات ثقافيه اصلا انا في
تصوري وفهمي للسياسه الخارجيه المصريه انه
بعد حققت مصر اهدافها في تحرير ارضها لن
يكون هناك مبرر لعمل عسكري الا للدفاع عن
النفس والدفاع عن الارض والدفاع عن
السياده وبالتالي مبرر العمليه العسكريه
في هذه الحاله هو عدم تهديد الامن المصري
وهذا يعني انه حدث حدث محدد من الجانب
الاسرائيلي يقتضي الرد مصر تحتفظ بقوه
عسكريه ترتيبها معروف في العالم من اجل
الحفاظ على امنها وقد راينا هذا يعني
عندما تدهورت الامور جدا في ليبيا وبدا ان
التدخل الخارجي في طريقه لان ينصر طرفا لا
تتفق معه مصر على طرف اخر ترى مصر انه هو
الذي يمكن ان يستعيد وحده ال الدوله
الليبيه القوه العسكريه المصريه مكنت
الرئيس السيسي من ان يقف في يونيو 20
ويقول ان هناك خطا احمر تتكلم على تركيا
حضرتك اه طبعا بس هل يعني ما هي دي النقطه
اللي انا عاوز اترحم مع حضرتك الكلام ده
كان فيما سبق ان مصر لن تستخدم القوى
العسكريه في مواجهتها مع اسرائيل او
الخيار العسكري الا اذا هددت مصالحها بشكل
مباشر ما يعني انه مصر لن تدخل في مواجهه
عسكريه مهما كانت العلاقات او تدهورت
العلاقات الاسرائيليه او مهما زاد العدوان
الاسرائيلي على دول عربيه اخرى مظبوط مع
الدكتور طبعا طيب في الحاله دي طبعا ده
شيء مؤسف لكثير من الدول العربيه شيء مؤسف
لاخرين ولكن مفهوم انما في الحاله بتاعه
غزه تحديدا المساله مش بنتكلم مثلا على
دوله عربيه مهمه لمصر لكن بعيده جغرافيا
زي لبنان او زي سوريا
رغم انه العدوان على هذه الدول يؤثر على
الامن القومي المصري لكن الوضع في غزه
بيتضاعف اهميته لانه على الحدود مع مصر
وبالتالي اللي بيطرح فكره ان العلاقات
تتدهور وقد تصل الى مواجهه عسكريه
بيتكلموا انه العدوان هذه
المره نواياه معلنه وهو دفع الفلسطينيين
دفعا الى سيناء او احراج مصر بشكل كبير
جدا بعدوان تقع فيه اعداد ضخمه جدا من من
الضحايا والشهداء الفلسطينيين بحيث يتوجب
على مصر ان
تتحرك انا اتصور انه السياسه المصريه لم
تستنفد بدائلها بعد وبالتالي اذا حدث هذا
السيناريو هو طبعا ما يحدث الان يعني بشع
ومروع بالنسبه
لاهلنا في غزه ولكن اذا استمر تفاقم
الامور اتصور ان لدى السياسه المصريه
بدائل مختلفه في مسانده اهلنا في غزه ليس
من ضمنها اعلان الحرب على اسرائيل لانه
اعلان الحرب على اسرائيل هذا قرار له
متطلبات
ا عسكريه واقتصاديه وسياسيه ويجب ان تكون
محسوبه وصانع القرار يدرك هذا لكن في
الوقت نفسه انا متاكد ان السياسه المصريه
سوف تجد اكثر من وسيله لكي تدعم بها اهلنا
في غزه ما هي تفاصيل هذه الوسائل يعني
بالتاكيد هناك اشياء كثيره للدعم لكن
اتصور ان التدخل العسكري المباشر لن يكون
من بينها قد يكون مثلا اتخاذ موقف شديد
التشدد في موضوع تقديم المساعدات لاهل غزه
يعني ان تكون المساعدات بغير اذن من
السلطان السلطات الاسرائيليه ولتفعيل
الاسرائيليه ما تريد ان تفعله ساعتها يبقى
لكل حادث حديث انما انا اؤكد على فكره انه
اتخاذ قرار بالهجوم على غزه مستبعده في
المهوم على الاسرائيليين بالهجوم على
الاسرائيليين الذين يعتدون على غزه هو
قرار مستبعد في المديين القصير
والمتوسط والا اذا حدثت احداث يعني لا
استطيع ان اتخيلها الان بحيث انه يبقى لكل
حادث حديث هناك طبعا على فكره انه عندما
يزداد توتر الامور ا بتحدث ا يعني مواجهات
بالخطا يعني لسه من ا يومين اعتذر الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه دبابه تابعه له اطلقت
النار على موقع مصري وحدثت اصابات طبعا
انت كررت هذه الاعمال بشكل يشكك في انها
غير مقصوده من الممكن ان تحدث تطورات بس
في هذه الحاله اتصور انه الرد سيكون يعني
متناسب يعني اذا انت قصفت لي موقعا بالخطا
ساقف لك موقعا بالخطا وفي نوع طبعا من ضبط
النفس بيبقى موجود على حسابات احنا قدامنا
مثال حزب الله او ليه بندور على على
المستقبل متخيل ليه هذا ما يحدث فعلا على
الجبه اللبنانيه اشتباكات شديده الانضباط
هي اشتباكات حقيقيه ولكنها شديده الانضباط
يعني مش مش بقى وفقا لنظريه الانتقام
الشامل التي كانت قائمه في ذروه الحرب
البارده انك ان اصبت لي هدفا صغيرا ارد
عليك بتدمير تماما وانما اصبت لي هدفا
صغيرا رد عليك باصابه هدف صغير مقابل
ويمكن فاتاني مش فاتاني يعني لما ذكرت ان
هناك مصر لم تستنفد كل وسائلها لا هناك
وسائل لدعم الفلسطينيين غير العمل العسكري
المباشر واكتفي بهذا القول يعني انه يعني
لدينا مروحه كامله من مساعده الفلسطينيين
اذا رؤيا ان هذا
ضروري ل ل تجنبهم يعني مصيرا
يعني يعني بالغ القسوه يعني مش لازم دعمهم
من فوق الارض ممكن من فوق الارض وتحت
الارض شكرا جزيلا مع الدكتور شكرا ل يا
شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم مع الدكتور
احمد يوسف في حلقات اخرى باذن الله